an Australian team recently reported in
nature the discovery of an extinct
fossil fish from around 318 million
years ago which gave birth like a mammal
now their research along with the
Natural History Museum in London has led
to an even more significant discovery we
think this latest nature paper is
incredibly important because it's all
about the origins of sex sex
invertebrates sex using copulation males
internally fertilizing the females and
that's intrinsically interesting I think
to everyone on the planet what inspired
the research were fossils collected from
a unique and remote site in Western
Australia the Go Go plan well I love
fieldwork it's is great getting out
there with a hammer and smashing rocks
and finding fossils I've actually been
working on this site Go Go in Western
Australia since 1986 and after 22 years
of collecting we've made some really
amazing discoveries the fascinating
thing about Go Go is that you're
actually standing in the reef you're
walking along the plain which is the
remnants of the seafloor and on either
side of you you've got the towering
cliffs which are made up of fossilized
algae and sponges fossils are the only
evidence we have of past life and
especially this group the placoderms
there's no living representatives now so
it gives us a window into our past the
truth is though that when you find
something you know wow I've just found a
fossil fish but you don't really know
what you've got until you bring it back
to the lab and prepare it out
and that's where the second wave of
discovery happens Zarina Johansson I've
collected fossils herself from the gogo
plane
the crucial techniques for extracting
fossil specimens were developed at the
Natural History Museum in London was
arena works as a paleontologist the acid
preparation technique which was used to
prepare these fossils from the gogo
formation was first established by a
staff member here at the Natural History
Museum back in the 40s his name was
Harry tooms and he was essentially the
fossil fish curator you take your
geological hammer and find one of these
nodules and you crack it open if you're
lucky
what you find is evidence
of bone within that nodule you close up
the nodule and glue it together and you
can take it back to the lab to process
and you put it into a dilute solution of
vinegar of acetic acid and the acetic
acid eats away all the limestone leaving
the fossil fish behind recently the acid
concentration has been drastically
reduced so revealing soft tissues never
before seen in such fossils was here
inside the adult mother fish with the
bones of a juvenile and unborn embryo
and still attached to it was a
mineralized umbilical cord truly one of
the most remarkable fossils found in the
history of paleontology finding an
intact umbilical cord is what proved
that matter piscis gave birth to live
young but the new nature paper asks was
this a very rare phenomenon this
specimen is the one that was described
in the new paper
it's a placa derm called in size sqm
Ricci I these are the plates of a
smaller placa derm housed within the
body of the larger placa derm now this
was originally interpreted as being the
last meal of this adult pachyderm but
because of the work that Kate and John
did we were able to reinterpret this
specimen and say that this is actually
an embryo within this adult pachyderm so
they now knew that another group of
fossil fish gave birth but at first the
researchers didn't see how these fish
could have had the sex needed for
internal fertilization if you look at a
model of these kinds of basic placa
domes you always see the pelvic fin is
being very simple but we discovered that
these fish had an extra lobe that
extended in the middle of the pelvic fin
then the penny dropped what John
realized was that the extra load was the
class / the male fish used to mate with
the female just like a modern shark
has--
so in other words these placa domes had
a pelvic girdle modified for copulation
so you know we have an expression that
humans like to get a leg over but these
black a' domes actually like to get a
leg in kateandjohn
with their previous nature paper showed
that you have internal fertilization in
this group called the tick da da da da
but our new work shows that you also get
internal fertilization or sex within
this very large group of pachyderms
called the arthri dyers so it seems to
be a more typical condition of the plaka
domes as a whole and probably now we
could say that it's a typical condition
of jawed vertebrates as a whole so
finally we had a model of how these fish
were reproducing and the fact that
internal fertilization and viv
apparently was much more widespread in
these early fossil vertebrates than
previously thought
the fossilized remains about 380 million
year old fish a placa dome an ancient
extinct group that's no longer around
today
it's the origins of true vertebrate sex
here back in the Devonian 380 million
years ago